the presidency of Donald Trump is not
only continuing to be a comedy of errors
it is supporting our report last week
which has since gone viral that Donald
Trump may sadly be suffering from the
early symptoms of dementia or
Alzheimer's President Trump just left
the Oval Office on Friday without
signing the executive orders that he was
there to announce after muttering a few
words to the microphone uh you're gonna
I'm gonna play the clip for you here
okay and you'll notice that Mike Pence
if you're watching that realizes Trump
didn't sign the Executive Order and and
sort of comes back into the room and
casually tries to grab it afterwards
I'll just take this pay no attention to
me and there's also a bizarre moment
which shows you the unraveling that's
going on at the Trump White House at the
end of this clip you'll see that a Steve
Bannon looks completely perplexed about
what he just witnessed Trump leaving
without signing the executive order and
usually when you're the president and
you're at the White House people open
the door for you right you always see
it's either Secret Service or aides
they're opening the door for the
president because no one had any idea
that Trump was about to just walk out he
sort of awkwardly has to open the door
and it's a moment like when George W
Bush wasn't able to get out of a room
during a visit in China or something
like that I don't know if you remember
that video Pat Hurley yeah it's also
strange because he's hosting people at
the White House - and he'd only show up
and speak for two seconds and take off
it's kind of rude isn't it bizarre and
it is continuing to fuel the idea that
Donald Trump may have something
cognitively going on let's take a look
at the video here thank you everybody
you're going to see some very very
strong results very very quickly thank
you very much the president today with
your tweet were you trying to tell the
Justice Department to grant immunity to
Michael Flynn when you try to do that
mr. president with that trend tension
with the president sir mr. president was
that your intention mr. president was
that your intention sir
their tents grab the executive order
they try to play it cool and people
start to wonder whether he signed it so
he didn't sign wow they were not pre
signed right he has yet to sign an exact
work if you know he signed them already
just that look on Steve Bennett's face
for those not watching it communicates a
very long uh-huh that that's what was
communicated by Steve ban and look and
it truly seems that aside from any
cognitive issues that could be going on
Trump is in a hell of his own creation
here right just sort of slinking out of
the room maybe it's depression I don't
know he's definitely upset my theory is
that he did initially forget to sign the
executive orders but realized that then
when pence reminds him he's like alright
I'm not going to turn around at this
point that would look even worse right
he says we'll just sign him in the other
room and it really seems like this is a
white house in shambles and our report
about Donald Trump's signs of early
dementia or Alzheimer's resonated with
many people and to be clear that's not
something to make fun of that's serious
you just don't want the president having
dementia or Alzheimer's and his body
language the way he just sort of
defeated Lee walked to the exits make me
think he is legitimately depressed and
or there is something cognitive going on
here
we suspected as a president that he
would just kind of be a figurehead and
sign things that other people had
written for him yeah apparently he's not
even able to sign the document no
somebody else has to actually remind
them that he's got to sign it and it's
now being discussed that may be the
reason Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner
are there is because of the cognitive
concerns another possibility that people
wrote to me about over the weekend will
continue following it